I know what you're thinking last week we
covered a lot of the Crowder and the
Shapiro stuff guys I know what you're
thinking you still would but you got to
remember that there was herpes
medication on her medicine cabinet when
she took a picture one time this is a
problem that is a when I pulled up this
video I was like oh Michaela ball fairy
it was like Michaela Peterson
talk finally going to give this what
we've been waiting for but what is
Michaela Peters whenever some big event
happens merch and I always go what is
the Army Queen Michaela Peterson have to
say about it so she decided to talk
about how great or how her experience a
daily wire was now before I pulled the
picture up the first thing I said before
I pulled the video up was that yes you
still would have to have sex with her
because yes she is hot
however she's insane oh absolutely bad
[__] this is a woman who is crazy
hey guys so I'm not sure if you've seen
But Stephen Crowder made a video about
an offer he received from the daily wire
he criticized DW ah yes Michaela
Peterson who's uh claimed the fame is
being Jordan Peterson's [__]
daughter I mean it's uh if you're gonna
talk about it if you're gonna split it
to its most basic atom yes oh I heard
that Andrew split it split her like an
atom oh and I'll say this I get I've
always gotten the impression that she is
an absolute [__] pigo oh yeah you
know what I mean on the floor I think I
think Tate cried after that's how
[__] nasty she is yeah you think you
think she she got him yeah yes yes
yes after it after after after [__]
her once takes out the phone calling and
apologizing to his mother yes I've been
a bad boy mom for supporting big tax
staring at the wall in the shower till
the water's cold
oh merch when you get a chance on the
rumble every once in a while just check
our comments depending on what the
timestamp in our video we're being
called daily wire juice sucking [__]
or or lefties lefties the lefties
lefties or were being called You're it's
either Crowder is right you guys are
[__] or Ben Shapiro was right you guys
are [__] or you guys look like [__]
that's just a neutral one listen if all
you fake neocon people that are like all
you millionaire [__] gatekeeping like
fake conservatives if you all hate me
like that and I guess we're on the right
track yeah yeah absolutely do it if one
side likes you more than the other then
you're doing too much 17th Jeremy boring
the CEO of not to be confused with
boring Jeremy the quartering yes gotta
remember Jeremy boring is the guy from
daily Wire yeah Ben Shapiro's business
partner uh boring Jeremy is the guy from
the quarter and with the meme veteran
hat you got to remember he's the one
sucking Crowder's dick right of DW made
a response video and then on January
18th Stephen posted another video where
he played part of a conversation with
Jeremy that he had recorded on the phone
without Jeremy knowing the whole dude
it's I honestly it is it's so funny
seeing this blow up in Crowder's face a
lot of people have been like
yeah wow dude wow like you register that
website before you left plays and then
you calling like look and again do not
have to take daily wire aside on this it
was a shitty contract yeah they're
shitty people
but they were being pretty transparent
with Stephen Crowder and he's doing some
Richard Nixon [__] like a lunatic here's
the thing with with the recording of the
contract thing because a lot of people
were commenting and I think rightfully
so to be fair going like look in this
day and age you should be recording your
contract negotiations in case they try
to [__] you which I find
I don't think recording them for your
own protection is one thing but
to make it like a bit on the show like
you understand what I'm saying there's a
difference right it's still recording in
secret is still yeah like I even brought
up on nightwave me and Royce have
recorded some conference calls we've had
with potential whatever whether it's
potential streaming platform or like a
[__] potential sponsor we don't
always do it but there are times when
it's like a new group of people we're
dealing with and we'll say right at the
beginning oh yeah hey we're on Zoom I
just well you know we're just recording
this you know just in case also for the
other reason because we forget you and
it's easy to go back and just listen to
it so it's just like hey I'm saying you
know we're recording this just to cover
everybody's butt and usually if if
somebody's not being I guarantee you if
Stephen said look I'm recording this
cover my ass Jeremy probably would have
been like all right it's fine whatever
yeah all things crazy given dad is
signed with DW
given dad a daddy
it's weird right my deity isn't that
weird I thought I'd comment a bit about
if you're gonna be a streamer and or
whatever you are
you and you call your dad even if you're
referring to your dad in this scenario
you say Jordan Peterson the contract my
father Jordan Peterson yeah that would
have been fine with that yeah who work
who Arc in his basement neocon be his
name and then help negotiate the
contract the dad signed as well as tell
you what working with DW has been like
also I like Stephen Crowder I think he's
extremely entertaining
all these people do is lie to each other
about how funny their friends they're
like L.A comics and yeah and oh God
they're like the LA scene I love them
great
[Laughter]
I've watched him comment on the election
it's funny my guess is the point of this
whole thing must be to launch something
that would be considered in competition
with DW his own platform that's my guess
I have no idea if that's true why would
you want to compete with Darkwing Duck
yeah no and that would nobody can it's
like you have no hope who's going to
pretend duck bro who's gonna protect
duck Burke think about it be fine duck
bird protect probably Jordan Peterson
see what I did there
Shapiro actually there you go duckberg
needs an Iron Dome
yeah and then you're not allowed to you
know you have one no merrier there
should be more conservative platforms
out there but that's no reason to tear
each other down hey I have an idea guys
it goes to one conservative platforms
make your own show and go to rumble you
get to keep all your [__] it's way
easier did you see the meme I read
tweeted the other day where it was like
it was a new political chart and it was
like big Tech friendly it was like it
was like one of those like uh spectrums
of like politics yeah they had like the
left and there was a box in there and
then a mini right and left and like the
conservative within that and then the
real right wing they were like big Tech
barrier and then real what right wing
was George Washington going why are
women voting yeah it went even further
and it was Louis XIV and he's like why
are people voting
and I was like dude that was the best
chart I like that I love it with the why
are women voting all the way back to
France and why are people voting why
why are voting
afraid drama you're not conservatives
you flew out what you [__] herpes to
bang a [__] kickboxer who runs a
[__] human trafficking cam or it's
like like none of you were conservatives
your dad named you after mikel's
gorgeous Gorbachev literally is what he
named her after and his entire house is
that for real that's for real and his
entire house is full of I didn't know
that like Kami like memorabilia
oh yeah I forgot about that
um I think everyone should have a bloody
neural link
tied to their Twitter account by the way
I Wanna
[__] him uh by the way I think we should
all get the bloody mark of the beast
what the [__] man get off Twitter guys
did you just spend the last like five
years relating [__] like the to the
the Bible what the [__] I will tell you
this tonight right after nightwave just
so you guys know okay and this is true
this isn't a joke right after night wave
at revengethesis.com if you go to the
shop we will be set and this is not a
joke this is really going up I'm just
waiting for you
yes we are we will be selling grifter's
tears hot or cold mugs and tumblers hi
everybody local Jew uh are you tired of
all of these grifters all these other
people just tell you to do this do that
do this that and they lie and they say
do this they do that well now you can
get a grifter's cheers Mark go go there
this afternoon right after afternoon I
would like to clarify that these mugs
are made in Taiwan which if you're a
real conservative you believe is
actually a separate breath than China
so those are going up oh I wanted to
give a shout out to goofy boots um he
got us yo this is tight these are these
Stone Cutters mugs but they they fit our
energy drinks in them how dope is this
by the way he made these so cool he made
a ring that you can drop in there so
that you can put shorter drinks in like
a beer or a soda yeah multi-use bro
thank you so much this is cool man this
I love this who keeps the metric system
down we do dude I was listening to that
song in the car wow does it hold true
now I'll I'll put it this way goofy
boots I don't really give a [__] a lot
about a lot of my you know glassware or
like mugs or Koozies but this is going
to go up there with my Yeti coffee mug
like the list of items that if it goes
missing or I can't find it for a day or
so I'll be like where the [__] is
it's meltdown worthy [__] yeah
I thought I should it's one of those
things of a significant other misplaces
it you're like where the [__] is that I
told you not to touch that and if you
bring this out in public you could drink
in public because it's like a brown bag
no one knows what's in here hell yeah
yeah
anyway in a soda can like look at the
gestures I'm always gesturing violently
you know so a can is really good for me
though that people working at DW are
locked into contracts they don't like
taking advantage of and forced to do
whatever DW says because that makes my
dad look naive and incompetent of which
well to be fair ever since he came back
from that [__] weird cloning lab in
Romania we're having a [__] stem cell
exactly torture lab you sent them to he
came back pretty weird wasn't it Russia
that was like Croatia no it was Moscow
it was literally yeah it was Moscow I
swear to God I remember this Moscow yeah
they had him in a [__] a medically
induced coma okay come on man
you know what it is Marsh
it's one of those Nick Fury robots like
from the uh Marvel presents Nick Fury
agency
David Hasselhoff's career is very much
alive dude no straight up Jordan
Peterson has [__] brain damage
there's no way he [__] does it they
had to put him in a medically induced
coma because of how much [__] Xanax
he was taking
he has a good one because he would have
died especially he would have died from
the [__] withdrawals if you went to
one of them bold and bankrupt hospitals
yeah luckily I've Got a Friend yeah you
always seem to have a friend and the
intelligence agency yeah you always seem
to have a friend that can get you on a
private plane to a [__] Clinic yeah
really nice
T is neither so I like Stephen again but
I think things need explaining on our
end anyway if who's our end you're are
do you own daily wire you're an artist
or an Entertainer or in my dad's case
um a pill addicted psychopath who's
taking out all his insecurities about
his mom on you and saying you're the one
with mommy issues when you're the one
that clearly has them
or or whatever you're gonna say I guess
is fine too intellectual internet dad
intellectual internet down you should
never be embracing that
Mercer's the Internet Cat dad we've been
calling him that yeah I care about the
kitties Internet Cat dad and you get a
contract but nobody should be nobody
like you should never trust anybody
who leans into that unironically that's
not a good thing that's not at the trait
of a good person nobody should be saying
my inner like I know I say it about Alex
Jones like he's my internet dad
um Steins says Tucker's is biological
that's just funny um but like if you're
pushing yourself to your audience as
like I'm up here right I'm lofty I'm
about I'm your dad you're all my kids
that's really creepy and it's you're
moving into cult world when you do that
[__] why are they so openly saying that
because they openly believe it yeah this
is the daughter of a clinical
psychologist promoting parasocial
relationships with her father this is
[__] insane thank you for making it
even more cutting but that's exactly
what it is that's 100 what it is you
read it thoroughly and you negotiate
until you ask hey you want to be Jordan
Peterson you want to be a Jordan
Peterson in the club yeah Jordan
Peterson fact Club is called the remoras
rather love it yeah they latch on to
whatever he says can't agree you go your
separate ways negotiate like a shark
it's not the contract like a remora she
has the emotional range of one she
literally just said negotiate like a
shark after my stupid Remora joke come
on ways negotiate like a shark it's not
the contract that you don't have to
science you know it's how well you can
negotiate if it locks you in she got the
mouth therapies of the downstairs herpes
we she might have none we don't know I'm
not going to say that she has anything
all I can tell you is that a picture was
blown up one time and she did post
herself on social media and a certain
convection Jewish radio host might have
went down and looked at everything and
saw some medication that is used yeah
that's all I just want to know because
those lips are looking juicy that's all
I'm saying
for years you better know what you're
getting into read it thank you she's
taking the stuff and she doesn't have
anything going on
that's the spirit boy
yeah I'm gonna be honest with you yeah
that's what condoms and prayer are for
yeah when you go waiting you see a meat
[__] like this you go in oh yes you do
I'll be fine I'm not gonna catch herpes
from her she's conservative and I'm not
gonna catch her because you can't catch
her twice
and you know her her dad won't let any
guy have sex with her until he has a
clean penis check so you know she good
yeah we think he does oral check on all
her boyfriend's penises yeah it's a
taste test taste and smell test tell
Andrew to bloody come in here Tom did he
eat pineapple like I asked him to
Andrew do I detect onion lawyers and
make a decision they're definitely naive
people who don't understand that's the
problem with this bloody meat diet it
makes the semen taste terrible oh she
probably has oh God and she she probably
has dudes that wanted a p that want her
to pee on them and her piece like keto
pee with smells really bad yeah drugs
and don't pay enough attention are too
young or are advised badly and they she
only eats meat so when she pees it comes
out like uh what the aliens acid spit it
just eats through everything sign up and
then say they're a musician they end up
losing you could pickle a cucumber
that's why they call him Andrew pickle
dictate did you know that
she's never had a cucumber every time a
[__] one comes close enough to her
yeah you have to put it in 70 of their
income for decades fortunately we hear
that pickle puss
hey sous-vide snatch how you doing
you're not nice
I'd also like to address the fact that
Dad retweeted Dad it's weird right
Steven's video to add to the drama
because Stephen robot trying to be human
it's all part of The Branding though
because you see she said your internet
dad and she's doing it it's all [__]
reinforcement well here's what she's
saying here and I think I think here's
what she's saying here what she's about
to say is Dad Jordan Peterson retweeted
Crowder's video Jordan Peterson
retweeted Crowders video before he knew
it was a daily wire contract and now
she's back she's backing up being like
well even Jordan's retweeted it but what
watch say they're a musician they end up
losing 50 seconds every time he says she
says dad from now on picture her saying
father this is a [__] cult I told you
yeah that's it this is all brand
reinforcement there's a reason she's not
saying my dad she's saying dad because
she established our internet dad and
she's kind of like one of the high
priestesses Church she doesn't want to
confused with Andrew
you know text the wrong one because how
she has them in her phone I think that I
think that the both of them would she
texts both of them the same way
oh God
answer she's a meat [__] the group
chat's titled The Butcher Shop
come for decades fortunately we are not
naive and we've negotiated business
deals before I'd also like to address
the fact that Dad retweeted Steven's
video to add to the drama because Steven
sent it around and dad does that to
support Stephen because we like but when
Steven sent it around so now she's
saying that Jordan retweeted it because
Steven sent it to him and now they're
saying that oh he did he who's daily
wire you know he works where he's trying
to [__] me now do I here's my thing do I
believe Steven sends it around to his
friends yes I do believe that but also
do I believe Jordan Peterson would have
retweeted that organically yes I also
think that yeah of course because it's
his buddy yeah dad found out what the
video was
when dad found out when dad found out he
was talking about our bosses I said oh
we take that back Dad agreed with it
initially because it's a horrible
contract when he realized oh my God
those are the people paying me and
Steven probably sent this to everyone
over at the daily wire like under like
under a certain level just because he
wanted to stir [__] over there too
because he knew he'd get other people in
trouble for retweeting I don't hate that
and when dad found out he'd be honest
with you I don't hate that I get it but
he's an evil no I know I know I get it I
get it but I'm sorry let me let me be
clear I'm let's just say this in the
right way
I don't hate the outcome no of course I
feel like John Levitz looking behind the
curtain in [__] Wedding Singer you
know I wish Stephen Crowder had dragged
this out a little while longer and then
revealed that he was a [__] so that he
could have at least done more damage to
daily one that's my only regret
he deleted the Tweet DW actually asked
him not to delete it because they said
it would look like they had asked him to
delete it but when Daddy asked wait so
hold on so this whole video
is now she is the cover for father as
you pointed out the high priestess for
the Church of Jordan Peterson Jordan
father made a mistake he texted her she
had to do damage control so she pulled
her [__] at Andrew Tate's ass and
[__] got the hell out gotta do it
but at that point it's your it's your
duty as my daughter to protect me from
the bloody troll demons they're so scary
they're cowards how many times she's
banging a dude and she has to go sorry
father's calling me yes papa
no don't stop
keep going and then she face calls him
and makes her dad go look he's eating me
out hello father my vagina is being
eaten right now what is it
yes I would love steak for dinner thank
you goodbye father and who's who's
eating you out and then all of a sudden
you're here now oh God no
gagging no Dave Lando
[Laughter]
the funniest thing he ever did by the
way if I was Dave Landau and I'll go in
to tell Crowder hey man look I'm gonna
go work for daily wire dude if I was
Dave Landau if I was him and Dave I mean
this sincerely and this isn't a joke
because every time people talk about
David this whole situation both sides of
it I'll go I think llano's a nice guy so
Dave Lana you need to get a shirt
that would work
I'd wear that yeah so that's the story
of the Tweet anyway let me explain a bit
about the deal why doesn't your father
explain I'm sorry you can't say your
father why doesn't father explain why
doesn't the whole father explain to us
seriously that's what they're hyping a
mess is he gonna come out this like
chubby [__] looking Bishop guy making
[__] Jesus clones is that what we're
doing
somebody please Photoshop him as all
father thank you
dad signed when we received we've got to
get bloody Humper to out there now
that was a great [__]
[__] what a [__] that you know
they did a good job of that show I hate
Seth Rollins 12 rules of killing
preacher
from DW to produce I eat the burger too
but that is a [__] great show yeah
and they did a good job with it podcast
Etc it was an all-encompassing offer
where DW would take over production of
the podcast and run and grow social
media channels and monetize YouTube and
dad would pee paid father a large amount
of money for that in a multi-year deal
so that he spent it on pills it was all
pills a lot of bloody pills we don't
need the AI thing I'll do it Jordan yeah
we got it it's no problem seems pretty
similar to the one Steven was offered
when you've built something yourself and
I started the social media channels
between like 2014 and 2017. oh and dad
started YouTube like decades ago and
Twitter whenever that started Jordan
Peterson poured his bowl of Xanax he
used milk
I think that Jordan Peterson I think
that she now is taking credit for Jordan
Peterson's social media accounts did you
see that she is she's like yeah but my
dad was nobody without me exactly
she's doing uh what's what's his name
um uh uh Mike
from uh from aggravator gamer from Angry
Video Game Nerd that's what she's doing
well actually I filmed the first AVGN
episode here's my penis on Reddit for
some reason
um [__] what's his name Mike mate Mike
mate there it is hey seriously look up
Mike mate penis read it it's a real
thing oh yeah when you build something
yourself I don't need that
you
first off
um I didn't say that you needed it I
said look it up
it was pretty intense to sign it over to
someone are you going to have it it's
just for you by the way keep it in a
personal folder yeah entitle it and make
sure it's like on a desktop or something
so like like your wife has access to it
so you make a desktop shortcut exactly
exactly that's not shirt that this is
and don't change the name no this is
what the shortcut is I want no I wanted
to say yummy yummy just for Daddy
Google Chrome Dash Mike mate's penis and
then in parentheses reddit.com forward
slash whatever yes I just cut to the
Chase and put the divorce papers on the
keyboard
all right I'm concerned for the fact
that he had them ready though well I
mean why do you why do you think he
asked for it why do you think he asked
for a legal soon login
just laid divorce papers on the table
that are dated like last year in August
yeah wait a minute how long have you
been thinking she said he said he found
him in her purse
yeah he found him on the same desktop
just title a document titled soon
actually that would actually be a funny
thing to do like if you have a shared
computer and you're married it's just
put it desktop icon and call it like
separation agreement and date it like
that day I love that that's really they
just write like haha just [__] in the
thing that's marriage humor